would you say the queen
no you're crazy
oh you crazy sorry
I am a queen yes I'm a drag queen I work
with children
all right
oh we found the virgin
that's the Asian art drawing naked
[__] yeah yeah okay I mean I've never
heard of it
look Little Mermaid black Little Mermaid
well
who really gives a [__] with this fake
fish is a black yeah
my whole thing is like I've dated a
couple black chicks and you cannot get
that hair wet
[Applause]
the mermaid part is the hair you know
and you can't have a Jewish mermaid
either because they can't [__] with
shellfish so yeah
and the people are mad about that I'm
like what a what a fun life you must
have but that's the biggest problem
if I go scuba diving you're gonna take
my wallet
okay all right hit me fatties let's do
it
wait I heard Elon Musk Elon Musk is
tough because uh I
oh we did we got Elon there Jesus Christ
somebody didn't finish high school but
all right um
[Applause]
elon's tough because a lot of people
hate that guy but I can't figure out why
you know if you're like ah like a lot of
progressive people hate Elon but I'm
like hey you know you're [__] on an
African-American over here
yeah he's a tough one I don't know and I
think he's clearly autistic so that's a
double whammy there
but yeah seems like a fun guy I don't
know all right all right when I heard
High School
what's going on with the uh there's a
lot of Lady teachers
[__] their students
that seems to happen more and more I'm
like
what is that is that like ladies can you
answer that is that the
is that because you know they can get it
up is that what it is you know
you might be with some 40 year old guy
you know he's got maybe one gray puke he
doesn't get it up all the time but that
14 year old he's rock hard in Geometry
yeah
so that maybe that's what it is maybe
they're like all right he'll definitely
get a boner and I can
getting a lesson
in Snatch as well so that's good you
know
she gives you an a you give her the D
all right
there we go
[Applause]
what else you got there oh Ukraine
tough one I pretend to care about
I will say all I know about the Ukraine
is that it was it's run the president is
a uh he's an ex comedian which you know
you don't want to [__] with us we're all
unhinged you know bedwetter molested the
whole thing you know we're all twisted I
mean how scary would America be if it
was run by President Katt Williams all
right
[Applause]
Kardashian hey that's a fun one all
right all right well uh
you know Pete Davidson's in there now
which is impressive because hey that's a
comedian and he's gentrifying her vagina
which is uh you know
you know it's usually a lot of black in
there and you know a Whitey came in and
uh I had to I had to clean up the
neighborhood you know
that's exciting
yeah
Kardashians are fun that's like eight of
them I like them they're they're they're
fun they're [__] they have fake asses
that's cool and they made a career out
of it good for them I say
I'm a fan I'm a fan
all right
prostitutes
is that what that was prosecutor
is that a lawyer ah
are you are you a lawyer
all right I think somebody killed her
all right
emotions I don't have those all right
come on
come on something I can use there please
Helen Keller holy [__] wow wow that is a
special lady there uh Helen Keller deaf
blind dumb right what is dumb you always
hear that now it's like deaf blind and
dumb what the [__] is dumb I mean
why do they always have dumb with those
I mean I figured they were dumb they're
[__] deaf and blind yeah they can't
read or watch TV and [__] so uh
how to get the new how do blind people
and deaf people get the news what do you
do
you got Braille I guess but you can't
really tell them how to use it I guess
yeah that's a tough one not to mention
the ass wiping that's the whole thing
there too but we'll get to that later
all right well let's uh this took a turn
all right let's let's pick it back up
here
Amber Heard Jada Pinkett all right we
got a couple toxic women here yeah yeah
[Music]
first off I think we should change the
term Karen to Jada first thing and then
uh secondly Amber Heard that that this
[__] trial has been going on for six
years now you know I just assumed Chris
Brown's watching that going I would have
knocked this [__] out years ago
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
um cancel culture yeah yeah yeah that's
a tough one well this set won't help me
on that
yeah I know my whole thing with kids
because it's weird people like it's not
real and I'm like
that's all we worry about you know it's
like uh
it's like that's not there I'm like wow
I can't see AIDS but yeah
I'm nervous although
Magic Johnson is still going so that's
good I mean hell he beat Kobe
all right all right
[Applause]
unlike him that joke landed
well there's your cancel culture for you
right there
alrighty alrighty
uh nurses are fun I like nurses because
uh they're they're just [__] and a
Tweety Bird outfit you know they got the
you see a lady in a Tweety Birds uh
scrub you know she does anal I mean you
know because
nurses all they deal with is needles and
bed pans and dead people I mean they're
not going to turn down a nice uh poke in
the pooper right yeah
yeah and they know the body who knows
the body better than uh than a lady in
the scrub right so
I'm gonna go with a nerd love the nurses
oh damn bed bug oh I've had those boy
bed bug is the closest I'll ever get to
being a nam vet because you wake up at
4am like what the [__] holy [__] Jesus
Christ God damn it's it's a nightmare I
do I I got a [__] new mattress I got
all my [__] cleaned I vacuum I got an
exterminator still couldn't get room
they're like they're like Puerto Ricans
I don't even know what that means but
all right
um
people
oh I mean there's nothing to say we're
perfect
joking ah
oh boy all right Santa Claus I don't
want to offend the Jews hold on
um
let's see Santa's fat uh how long till
he changes genders that's gonna happen
it's gonna happen
kids are on his lap he's uh using he's
got a he's got a warehouse with midgets
in it he's not paying him you know
Santa's on the way out I think yeah
uh what else did I hear sorry we gotta
wrap this up
La a lot of hobos out there that's tough
not sure what to do there what are we
gonna do with the hobos I can't figure
that out maybe we should make them
maybe we should take the sweatshops from
China
hobos work there
because these Chinese kids are uh
they're they're they're making Nikes
they're making iPhones you know that's
why it's weird when you see like this
these black guys videos them beating up
Chinese people you're like well who's
gonna make the Jordans
any question there turtleneck you good
what an Asian joke okay
all right let's start some Asian hate
here now
I don't know many Asian jokes I'm a fan
I'm an Asian supremacist you guys are uh
toughest people don't know why you're
here you should be working sir
yeah come on I want you to learning the
cello studying or sitting on a box
feeling something God damn it yeah
you're not allowed to have fun
yeah Asian Asian people are cool because
uh you guys just stay quiet and go to
work you know every other group's like
proud of themselves every group's got
like a slogan you know black people are
like I'm Black and I'm Proud white
people like white power or Asian people
are like
I'll be doing Blackjack here yeah
I like that
and you guys are killing it lately I
mean you got crazy Rich Asians you got
that uh Marvel movie shinshi or whatever
squid game I feel like Asians are
cooking right now
it's killing it Ali Wong and
yeah
what kind of Asian are you in
oh Taiwanese
that's a good one
great great food
brown nipples
all right
wait is there a difference between
Taiwanese and Thai
they're different places right there's
Thailand and Taiwan sorry sorry okay
sorry I put that together myself I got
it I got it
sorry about that sir
but you know people get mad if you get
their country on like you call me
Canadian I don't flip out
all right well thanks for coming what's
what's the Taiwanese thing you know
China it's like aha Wuhan we got it uh
you know good food Eggroll
Thai Thai is like Pad Thai Korean is uh
Kim Jong-un
what's Taiwanese thing
ah
what are we talking potato or corn
I'm joking
all right hi tech chip manufacturer all
right that's cool I didn't know that
thank you
see people get so weird about racial
stuff when you touch on Race we're like
oh what I'm like now I learned something
so I think it's good to lean in take it
easy
very nice I appreciate it just feels a
little make-a-wishy you know
the [__] boy
all right
get out of here you guys have any
questions
am I [__] I hope not I mean my
career would be going great if I was
[__] how functioning would I be huh
I mean I drive a car and [__] I've
gotten laid Yeah
yeah I could be the first [__]
comedian I guess
anybody else other than maybe it's not
so insulting
well I mean Norm is up there uh it's
tough tough because uh there's so many
good ones you know I like I like Cosby's
later work but
um
I never caught a stand up
[Music]
oh
well I I pray to Allah so I don't know
about the Bible I don't know much yeah
what praise Allah exactly yes he's good
yeah 72 virgins that seems like a lot of
hymens
um
who wants to put that many towels down
you know
Jesus Christ
where's Joe oh he's at a gig somewhere
else yeah
people ask that a lot they always want
him to be under the stage or some [__]
but yeah he's uh he's my podcast partner
and he's also a comedian so he's doing a
show because he's trying to be a
comedian as well so uh
that's that I went and saw Seinfeld when
I was in college and somebody went
where's Kramer and he was like well he's
not real you know
little did we know he was on the uh
stage at Laugh Factory saying the n-word
but uh
[Applause]
that was a different time in a different
place
but thanks for the shirt there he's he's
cute all right I guess we gotta this is
getting awkward it feels like we all
[__] and I won't leave
uh I'll see you guys are great thanks a
lot Nashville
thank you we got a wheelchair guy hey
[Music]
there's two here two wheelchairs
oh hey we're on a roll all right
all right thank you I think that joke's
got legs but um
that's wheelchair jokes you know it's
not really my wheelhouse but um
all right
was it was it uh born with it or is it a
was it an accident
what happened
all right well I think we'll all be
drinking and driving tonight so
um it's a little awkward at least you
get the license plate I guess you got
the parking all right cool uh-oh this
lady's leaving never a good sign I think
it's gonna walk right in front of that
guy that's a little insensitive all
right what do you got sister are there
more doors or wheels in the world
whoa somebody in and edible
[Music]
that's a great well I'll probably go
doors because they were invented before
Wheels no way the wheel was done by
cavemen that was a stupid thing to say
all right I'll go Wheels then because
everything's got more than one except
for a unicycle so there's a multiple
wheel
I'll go wheel there's a lot of cars on
the road out there that's cars planes
bikes scooters skates
oh yeah Hotel yeah
that's a lot of doors yeah
and when God opens the door he doesn't
add a wheel I'll tell you that you know
still go on Wheels but we'll talk we'll
talk now is that googleable when's
Google gonna really good like hey you
know like how big is my dick Google you
tell me I want to see if you know and
then I'm like
five inches I'm like damn they're pretty
good all right
I'm joking I think somebody's gonna
bring up the [__] squirrel in the
room
I mean are we gonna talk about this
sir
you've been waiting for
that haven't you
I want a front row seat what's that
no you've soaked up enough attention
with the [__] rodent on your head can
you come on stage
no that squirrel found its nut I'll tell
you that right now
God damn it
[Applause]
I think you were bred for this [__]
Garfield well sir
you hate Mondays and I hate you
by the way I'm starting to think coven
started with you yeah
not the Chinese thing just the [__]
squirrel all right
is that thing real
yeah is it oh my God I bet you killed
the class pet when you were younger
didn't you and you kept it you stuffed
it and you put it on your weird hat
the Hat was already atrocious but you
had to put it dead
animal on top of it all right
it bothers me that you probably get laid
a lot too which is uh
a little off-putting
okay boy Peta if they catch you they're
gonna really beat the [__] out of you
who get me a [__] straw what are you
one of these Turtle Advocates what the
hell is going on here
straw backstage
out of all that the 12 minutes on [__]
she's like that [__] straw I'll tell
you
that really broke the camel's back huh
take it easy lady is it the turtles or
what is it
well I shouldn't I gotta stop bringing
my sponsor out
a blue over there what was that
what's that
we love you mark wait what did I do
wow
supporting prostitution yes I've given
them money for years
you don't know me you [__] psycho
[__] shut up
so crazy you think you're the good guy
in the movie you know
[__] [__] all right um oh is that
her oh great all right wait what did I
do why are you mad I don't get it
what do you mean I'm promoting it I'm
telling a joke you [__] psycho Jesus
Christ
I don't think she's smart
suck my dick all right well
that's sexual assault you're promoted
you guys have any questions
all right that's not much
[Applause]
what's my Halloween costume I think I'm
gonna go as uh
yeah I live in Manhattan
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
anybody else wanna charge the stage
my comedy honestly
come on tick tock
what are you doing tonight Karen dinner
what do we think of here
what are you doing later what's your
idea of a fun night a bubble bath and a
Danielle Steel novel let me talk
I don't think you know a lot of black
people but I bet your dildo is black I
don't know why
oh yeah
diversity right
but if I'm being completely honest I'm
jealous of immigrants my buddies of
Mexican everyone has been here like
eight years he loves America but he
never thinks about the bad parts we get
a lot of bad history you know huh
why not
oh it's already invest your immigrant
test
Christ
all right can we Deport her what do you
think
[Applause]
I don't know I don't know because I'm
from here I mean if it helps I got him
out of a cage but uh
all right well thanks that joke's ruined
all right cool
[Music]
lady
I know you're gonna
first time well you know I don't like to
talk about your mom but uh
hey look who woke up all right
good to have you back you [__] idiot
here you go hey who knew all right white
pants bad for spotting all right
um
as a first date oh all right well glad
you guys decided to come here and chit
chat
[Music]
biracial relationships well the porn is
great uh
I don't know about the relationship it
is oh boy I'm glad you're dating her not
me but um holy [__] it's nice to know
you guys are I thought you were mail
order so uh you know
[Music]
sorry I'm just getting uh get my revenge
you guys were the horrible table all
night yeah I had a guy come on stage
um but this was his fault like he was
heckling me for like an hour and
eventually was like [__] you and I'm
just trying to like avoid it and he was
in the front row so he was saying it
just to me oh so he's like you thought
that joke's like you suck everybody
hates it you know he was like needling
me and I no one else could hear it so I
was like all right [__] it and I'm doing
well whatever and then I just snapped he
could only take so much and I go [__]
you you piece of [__] I'll kill you you
know and everybody in the back's like
whoa where'd this come from so they
start defending him so I'm like no you
don't know he's been [__] on me the
whole time like we didn't hear anything
and I'm like no no he's like he's loving
every minute of it and then I just went
in on his appearance and he got up and
he was like that's too far and I'm like
oh now you're pissed like welcome to my
world so then he comes on stage and uh I
don't know what happened I think I
kicked him or so because I had I had
some elevation so he was walking up the
stairs and I did one of these no way
yeah and uh the bouncer finally came
black acidic Jews is that you sir whoa
look at him
holy [__] that's a crazy combo huh you
must have the curliest hair on the
planet holy hell
you know foreign
[Music]
you could be an athlete and your own
sports agent
what's your name sir
fun you know like uh Arsenio Weinstein
or some [__]
hello yes exactly
what's that
you're killing me
[Applause]
it's all weird you know it feels like
someone said the n-word at a Tyler Perry
movie
Jesus Christ you don't see this [__]
during this the only like art form this
happens in you know this doesn't happen
during Hamilton you know we were all
[__] in the shower and she had to
flush the toilet
appreciate it that's very nice with the
Clapping just feels a little
make-a-wishy
come on
[Music]
I wish you were a Chinese balloon I'd
shoot you down
how was the whip it not good don't ever
do it sir
they'll rot your brain you'll be an
idiot you'll be like her and brutal you
don't do
it they're bad
they make you disregard other people's
feelings and ruin [__] and inconsiderate
so yeah stay off drugs kiddo don't you
know go to school or whatever
I think uh for coming to the show
yeah
all right she's gonna be annoying I can
tell
[Music]
you sir I'm worried about you guys
you guys look like a moment
why you're turning things off can you
turn those guys off they won't shut the
[__] out
he's like half of half of them good for
you
hey I'm not that cute
what happened
what are you talking about sure
oh geez now you're getting re-hippled by
your own eyes
we should just kick her out I completely
agree but that's apparently up to the
club and uh I don't know what they're
doing but try to get this show right
back on the road
it feels like someone said the n-word in
a time of pairing mode all right
Sterling go back to my squad stickers
[Applause]
[Music]
Danny Norman that was terrifying what
happened the rehab center to a field
trip what's going on I can't realize no
wait a minute I'm not a serial killer
crazy dude
I think we all agree that I think the
staff went home
we're all the same color on the inside
[Music]
I guess I'm just gonna
keep it going
[Applause]
this guy's sneaking off
well now you're flicking me off what the
hell
what'd I do
I don't know you what is going on with
this group so where can I
what the hell
my phone's ringing
[Applause]
my fingers I think they're gonna put it
for sale sign on this one a global
thickness in the hallway you guys are
great thanks for coming out
[Applause]
what about the Jews what's that what
about the Jews
Jesus Christ
well well well
man oh man I've never seen a race war
that quick holy [__]
that was wild
I didn't know we had Palestine over here
on the right side
holy hell all right well this is getting
a little kooky what the hell's going on
in here
hopefully this thing [__] him not [__]
them
because look we need to keep this
weather all right don't [__] with these
guys
[Applause]
geez Louise sorry there you face you
really got uh
you always hear about oh anti-Semitism
it's around you're like all right shut
up you [__] pee but you know and then
and you see all the
[__] uh what's his name Abu grave or
whatever the [__] yeah
Arafat what's the guy's name I can't
keep up
um cool all right let's uh let's wrap
this thing up with a bow this is off the
rails here
um
okay
I've been doing comedy 15 years I've
never seen someone say [__] them
to an entire race of people that was
wild
all right
this guy's a [__] psycho huh
man oh man we got Nick Cannon here I
think huh
Geez Louise
I know I look like a Jew but I'm not I'm
just uh you know all right cool
all right there's somebody gonna tase
this guy or what I mean ridiculous what
are they doing here can I hit this guy
with a chloroform or some [__] all right
you'll find me the guy with a swastika
on his neck yeah that'll be the guy
there you go all right
um cool okay well this is uh we're gonna
we're gonna try to land This Plane I'm
like Captain Sully here you know
there's a [__] seagull in my engine
and I'm like
all right here we go
um
oh hey
appreciate it it's very nice you know
very nice builds a little make-a-wishy
but uh yeah there you go I was I was
just up in Canada
[Music]
well this is this is not a speed date
I can't always show you weirdo I don't
think you know how this works this is
why people stop coming to Poughkeepsie
ah the show boys
yeah that was horrific
[Applause]
you guys hear that thing holy [__] sound
like the Spy balloon was deflating
all right man you want to talk now
[Music]
when did you get to Nashville
I love it okay okay
thank you I'm not much to tell I was
raised
get to it
we're aware
you were a guy you have been kicking the
balls by now